I am broken by so many things Khloe
Kardashian brought to tears in the
latest trailer for Keeping Up with the
Kardashians it's always difficult when
somebody goes through a rough time and I
think one of the things that has made
the success of the show is that we show
those vulnerabilities and we're also
transparent and you do see how it
actually unfolded in what happened
because everybody thinks they know the
whole story and they don't we see the 34
year old reality star gets super
emotional after learning her boyfriend
Tristan Thompson allegedly cheated on
her with Kylie Jenner's best friend
Jordan Woods for you and Jordan it's
like a divorce she does just know I love
you the rest of the season has so many
crazy things going on and as I say every
time you guys ask it's just tune in
because you never know what's gonna
happen this is my life the drama doesn't
end there
seems Kendall is pretty pissed too I
don't understand how my own sister is
like talking about me I didn't even know
there was a problem she will go out of
her way to make me look crazy we'll have
to stay tuned for the sister standoff
but as for Kendall's love life well a
source tells e.t she single after
splitting from her NBA player boyfriend
Ben Simmons quote the two are on good
terms both Kendall and Ben are extremely
busy
and for now the relationship does it
work for them on the flip side the
trailer has plenty of light-hearted fun
moments
[Music]
hopefully this means we'll get to meet
the latest kiddo in the Kardashian crew
Kim and Kanye's son Saul mama Kris
recently told et the meaning behind his
nickname the inspiration was the Book of
Psalms in the Bible so I think it's just
a wonderful way to celebrate you know
how they feel and he's such a blessing
so it's perfect he's just adorable